you are raising a lot of money for
children who were ill Yasim with cancer
and we were going to talk about a lovely
charity called Alex's Lemonade you might
be officially Alex's Lemonade Stand it
raises money for research to find a cure
for pediatric cancer and if you know
nothing about me is two things Juana I
ate I hate cancer mm-hmm and I love kids
so here's the deal you go to a omae's
dot-com slash tim and ten bucks that's
okay and you come you come out they'll
fly you out to LA you people don't need
to be flown you're already here but
literally you fly out to LA they're
gonna put you up in this really nice
hotel Suzanne Goin for going from AOC
those two guys from animal and yeah John
and Vinny's these are amazing chef
edible shouting chefs the pastry chef
they're gonna make us dinner we're the
you and whoever your friend but it's
annoying we're gonna have get it wrong
like ten bucks and they'll do it it's a
ten bucks in here and kinda just did
imply their dollars and everyone cares
it's for a good cause
no drawing if you lose you're just real
good about yourself right okay there and
if you win we're gonna at world I win
we'll have dinner together
it'll be like this conversation but
you'll be more interesting probably
Coenen let me tell you something if you
think let's have it here you were so
pulling me back over again here we go
yeah I was this close to like by the way
by the way it doesn't you could come and
join me I mean if you hate cancer you
love kids it's not that's okay but if
you love kids you could join me for
dinner and then the white party maybe
you could I'm not no pressure hey Conan
will you help fight cancer yeah my
sports car
of course I'm losing weight that's a yes
yes of course it would be great so you
and I would have highways so it so if
someone wins they have dinner with us
yeah and we will recreate this magic
[Applause]
yeah yeah I know wait a second oh I know
I probably shouldn't sit at the same
table I'm a noisy eater when they first
asked me to about this doing this I was
like so let me get this right
these celebrity chefs are gonna make me
dinner and the winner gets to watch and
they're like no the winner would sit at
the table with me if it's pretty kids a
good thing I thought it was enough just
to be fun when you're at a restaurant
you're like oh right
look there's a celebrity having dinner I
thought there gonna be a bow not
standing outside to win yeah like a kid
little rat watching you eat okay now you
go to that website it's now officially
you're having dinner with the three of
us right oh this is great I think this
is gonna be great right yeah I wish you
hadn't sang that this is where I want to
be song
you